hey folks please enjoy this clip from
our show which you can find every single
day at 400 p.m. Eastern exclusively on
Rumble we've been doing the best shows
we've ever done completely free of
censorship and on a platform that
actually supports us you can also
support us on locals where you can
access a ton of exclusive content movie
riffs as well as an archive of over a
thousand full episodes going back as far
as 7 years we've also teamed up with
merch engine to bring you a new lineup
of really awesome quality shirts hoodies
and now even hats so come check out our
untethered uncensored show on Rumble
every single weekday at 400 p.m. Eastern
you stupid
idiots prison rape prison rape a lot
yeah a lot of those a lot of women
getting raped in prison Jim Norton's
wife oh god dude damn how's that they
have a YouTube channel now that is our
chras that's the Christmas present this
year for me is that they're that she's
using him to to launch her trainy
influencer career and it's the be did
you see they started a YouTube no they
started a YouTube channel really yeah
like it's Jim Norton and this [__] now
and they've even got the little ding
little subscribe buttons pop it up over
you can tell the TR what's it's called
give me that link vgy check uh just
check his Twitter I think he tweeted it
up I got
you oh my god
really oh yeah I can't I love it I love
this he's gonna kill
himself yeah I've been saying that for a
while yeah Jesus
Christ Nikki and Jim NY see oh yep there
you go oh I'm sorry Virgie I should have
clarified I hate
him oh okay well then so this isn't a
bit huh he really married a [__] huh
yep wow that's his thing look at this
man unbelievable bro this is my wife's
sneakers oh I love those on you oh my
God I would love it if you were Nikes
they're giant are we sure this isn't a
bit I mean I don't know man I know some
CH I know some actual hot chicks that
he's dated also like that aren't
[__] I
do all right yeah it's a [__] look
whatever man I'm just I'm just look man
I don't I used to like Norton and I
understand the whole [__] jokes and
this and that but like yo you're
marrying one like you're marrying a
[__] MH well think about it though
think about think about this from a a
show business perspective okay if you
already like [__] anyway it's not a
stretch to if you're not ashamed to walk
around with one and suck off
in public right like it's not a big leap
to marry one and he's irrelevant now are
you saying are you saying it's like Dan
Schneider working at Nickelodeon if you
already love molesting kids you might as
well get a job in show business with bar
a bunch of kids okay pays well s to so
he's I think he's like Jim and Sam
nobody watches Jim and Sam that's not
true nobody watches it nobody's tuning
again more people are watching us Chad
I'm sorry people do listen to Jim and
Sam have you ever rented a car yeah and
then I change it to [__] lithium I
put it on I put it on yach Rock that's
what I listen to I put it on lithium's
90 90s
music no but I mean yeah you know what
I'm sorry uh people do listen to Jim and
Sam the girlfriends of the comedians who
are on that day are the only ones that
are tuning in um but yeah nobody's
watching Jim and Sam when was the last
time you saw Jim Norton do anything
since ow there's no movies there's no TV
shows the biggest thing I guess that he
had but but that's you know what even
using that logic because that was that
was created on OA was the chip
chipperson podcast which was de actually
got decent numbers right but it wasn't
something new it was something it was a
hold over from the OA day so that's a
really good point I can't think of that
I think that somebody's worried that the
contracts are coming up soon and that
they might not renew their show and that
somebody was probably somebody's
probably getting advice from younger
Comedians and maybe like agents and
stuff going yeah everything's hot on the
internet now you got to do something hot
on the the internet and he's already
[__] [__] anyway why not start a
[__] reality wife show it's dude this
guy gave up his soul a long time ago
anything to keep the paycheck so so you
don't think the Taiwanese holding
company that old Sirus is going to reup
their contract really no [__] way
because then they won't have enough
money for stern oh fair enough
yeah and you know what they say big feet
big yeah I get it but the other thing is
like
okay on the probably really married to
[__] but but also I want to judge us
on the comedic aspect of this he's still
doing the [__] jokes
Circa so you want to 2004 five which by
the way I don't think the trans
Community would appreciate right like
that you're still using them as like a
like a weird F you're fetishizing and
using them as like a weird like what
we're going to make dick suck yeah Jim
you're lucky if these kids could read
they'd be really
pissed but I'm pretty sure the tranes
don't want to be used as a punchline gy
no and this whole thing this whole thing
is going to be one long punchline about
[__] a
[__] don't shoot me yet I want to fix
this toilet wow is he really doing like
a Kardashian with the Subscribe and the
music and the yeah dude I was I had to
show
this what the flying [__] are you doing
Jim clinging to relevancy holy [__] and
they know by the way they know it's it's
brilliant when you think about it right
cuz it's her channel so she can say you
can fill out that demographic thing that
YouTube has where it's like I'm a trans
person and they're going to get in the
algorithm more it's brilliant I mean
yeah that's a good point I guess they
they will never dare pop it Tik Tok
Clips are coming soon too watch that
that'll be next yeah you're right it's
decep wait now it's stopped yeah cuz I
flushed what did you not flush before no
I didn't what happened all that weight
you lost little Jimmy Norton didn't you
lose a bunch of weight what happened he
lost you know me me and Royce have had
conversations about Jim Norton like
weight loss and [__] and he did this
like weird gay guy thing where he just
lost weight like Al Roker but he melted
but it's like yeah any man like women
and men are different if you're a woman
yeah you should try to lose weight you
shouldn't try to
obviously like women shouldn't everybody
has a different preference I know you
like like women are a little muscular
yeah yeah I like I like I don't mind
like some ABS but I don't want a chick
who's ripped right women should if
you're chunk no not too vascular to
vasular on like just kind of losing the
weight vasular weird women have to do
more cardio and butt squats right but
like if you're a dude you should never
be just trying to lose weight you should
be trying to lose weight and gain muscle
because it'll first of all it's a lot
faster if you're doing both to
eventually get to a place where you go
[__] I look better you know what I mean
and guys look better with mus like if
you got to put some [__] muscle on
and Jim has the money if it's if it's a
metabolism thing you get some [__] gu
man he's his 50s they give it to him
just walk F in they'll give it to you
right away at him yeah here you go he
could have been 20 and they would have
looked at him and been like here yeah
don't use her his it's hormones cuz
those are the opposite ones you don't
want those you want the the the other
way now if now if you were F if you were
fighting the other way around if it was
female to male yes take their hormones
you want
those nuts that septic tank okay good
job you just flushed the toilet and
fixed it hear me out hear me out future
episode of the show they're trying to
get ready for like going out to like
some [__] wedding or restaurant
doesn't matter and they're they're like
[__] shuffling for their their their
testosterone and their estrogen and they
accidentally bump into each other and
they spill it and then Jim Norton ends
up taking estrogen for like a month or
two it looks like he already has look at
that profile look at that profile look
at that profile I like this too cuz like
Virg's coming up with sort of like a
Freaky Friday but with a scientific
angle instead of like a you know all
those body switching movies it's always
like some magic [__] but like virie
smart we're do we we'll do like a what
was the other movie Freaky biday we'll
call it yeah what was the movie Freaky
Friday was based on it had like
[__] Mo was in it uh n God I know
exactly the one you're talking about
that one was cool too there's a lot of
body snatching oh not body snatch body
switching
movies well face off I guess was a
scientific one that wasn't body that was
that was a different but it's still the
same cuz you know you're still this
different guy I like to think of this
one as like a body switching movie but
like also an a front to God okay all
right so like a sin a moral sin and a
body switching movie got it got it got
it got it inspired to
buy vola Vasa I don't I have no idea but
when I went to Sharon os's party she
were giving out free candles Dro that
name and I believe that this was never
name dropped J Moore taught me that this
is the other thing that I'm going to
I've been I've been covering this a
little bit cuz they have an Instagram
too so I've been covering this on night
with of course they on the gram of
course of [__] course and I've been
watching their little cute shorts and
stuff and if there's one thing that
we've been noticing on nightwave it's
the the obsession with status meeting
celebrities free stuff like this person
is a [__] leech and a clout Goblin
and a and so the trans
person got
him but dude I'm telling you Jim Jim's
not going to put up with this for n nah
and by the way I'm going to ask a
question that we're all thinking nobody
wants to say it who's the top who's the
bottom oh yeah yeah this thing's
definitely the top and how long before
how long before we hear that Jim is the
victim of Dating Violence oh domestic
showing up showing up to Jim and Sam
with a black eye no he would never show
it off it would be sunglasses oh yeah
rocking sunglasses the whole time yeah
so imagine they go to bed at night hey
Jim cut off the
lights it's one of them and I love it
and it was that was a complete name drop
by the way this candle yeah you just did
that whole thing he could say Sharon
yeah by the way Jim you seem very
natural on camera and your head's not
shaped weird at
all wow that's like pereria head huh he
does look like a I'm getting
stronger love you
Shon y so I know it's going to try it's
it he's he's embracing now like it's fun
like we're just having a fun that he's
going to start hate cuz she Nam drops in
every video everything's always like oh
remember when we went to birth chist
thing it's just it's like oh this [__]
every video on Instagram is like them
backstage and like hanging out with
security bags it's it's bro I'll put it
this way right if I was [__] like a
real chick that was hot and like I was
like you know whatever if I had some
[__] hot 28-year-old girlfriend that
was coming out with me everywhere you
ask you you know if I started noticing
like patterns like that I would drop
that [__] in a heartbeat even if they
if they started doing like oh we're
backstage and blah blah blah we just did
that' get old with me real quick that's
why it didn't work out with lummer and
merch she kept name dropping that she
knew Charlie Kirk do you want to meet
him no it's okay two guys are seeing us
you're like oh my God she's like you
know uh you know I know uh uh Charlie
Kirk like to meet him uh do I have to
get out of this chair like forget about
going to another place do I even need to
get out yeah sure I'll meet him can I
meet him right
here he's with that gay black guy dude
that's how me and Royce were like even
at the the shooting range with like
other creators that were big but we
didn't care about I don't care about
that guy like Undertaker Chuck Liddell
was cool coffee Zilla was cool dut
operator was cool there were some cool
people uh George was Co cool but like as
far as like when people go Hey look it's
so and so just like yeah I I I was like
I don't know who that is but to be fair
some of the coolest people we met there
were like either not content creators or
just like friends like the dude that had
the deadlifts and freedom shirt and then
we go talk to him and he's [__]
missing a leg he was one of the coolest
guys like he had lost a leg in the war
and and he was just the [__] most
chilled dude and I'm like you still de
go yeah goes the first thing I asked
when I lost my leg is can I Deli and
they were like yeah I was like hell yeah
brother I'm like this guy [__] rules
he tell you he lost his leg in the war
that's what I heard did I did I mishear
it did you specifically did he say that
or did you just assume he lost it I
assume because he said it was overseas
yeah see you don't know what what what
would have happened overseas a smelting
accident have you seen
Europe maybe I guess Poss I always do
that to people like whenever like
somebody sees like a soldier in cammies
and they're missing a leg and they're
like oh man he lost his leg in the war
like do you know that though diabetes
exactly but I always try to call it do
you know have you asked yet I want to do
that every time I see a veteran with a
missing limb did you lose it in the
war and then if they go yeah obviously I
go what that's not a stupid question you
go fishing you could be on a [__] you
could be a paragliding incident
somewhere in Gaza who knows you're an
[__] no I'm saying I'm not a fan of
Music Festival if if the Rope thing cuts
his arm off G I got what you meant she's
[__] giant yeah and I am big
but you're you're you're tall you're
tall and slender you're tall and slender
Nordic
dude yeah you look like a [__] one of
one of uh the henchmen from Die Hard mhm
like you're obviously from Norway or
Finland you're tall you're very slender
and look I'm gonna be honest with you
you'd probably make a really hot
dude right am I
wrong right like a scars guard or
something like somebody from the scars
Guard Family where you're like that's a
good-look dude with a lot of Nordic
Chans in them but you're not a woman
yeah actually in another life she would
be telling me ah you're awake well I'm
in a
wagon um look at the size of those big
boy boots those are some guy
Boots the Uggs a life Lee you forgot the
Lee
part Dude Looks Like David Bowie on the
weekends oh [__] now he's not that mean
of the Monarch feminine no matter what
you do your brother's reference going to
think you're a man with ugs can you
imagine the same the same culture that
created this [__] Abomination also
created Andre brevik yeah you know just
talk about two sides of a different two
two different sides of the same coin
well we'll be watching our favorite
reality show I'm sure moving forward
this is let me subscribe what am I doing
oh I'm excited boom I'm excited to cover
this one I was I was happy to bring this
along cuz uh yeah we need to be on this
yeah no no absolutely
uh how long you think before uh you
know I mean Norton's been really sad for
a long time I don't
know